we have a subreddit for the David Pakman
show which is one of the larger sort of
single show subreddits for progressive
media we have over 16,000 of our viewers
and listeners subscribed at david
pakman.com slash reddit won this is
there's actually more than one example
but i picked one there are a lot of
posts showing up on our subreddit about
people concerned at Bernie's dropping
poll numbers here's one example from a
user named some jerk 27 who says Bernie
Sanders has been dropping in the polls
there's been a lot of talk about Buddha
judge rising and Warren going down but I
haven't heard as much about what's
happening to Bernie Bernie picked up
some speed in the last two months
getting up to 19 percent on average but
in the last couple of weeks he's fallen
down again to only 15 percent he's still
technically in second place but that's
only because Warren continues falling
this is worrying for me as a Bernie
supporter we've got to find a way to get
him back up again stop Buddha judged
effect a defeat Joe Biden although I
don't like her as much as Bernie
Warren's fall is also worrying so there
are a lot of people sharing this concern
I'm actually going to be doing a
commentary will I will explain how the
establishment getting behind Pete Buddha
judge actually helps Joe Biden even
though the instinct might be that it
divides the establishment vote between
Biden and Buddha judge and this is
playing into the dynamics of what's
going on with Bernie and Warren all I
can say to you is while I don't believe
that the polls are inaccurate it is
still early enough that anyone who's in
the running can still win there are four
key primaries Iowa New Hampshire Nevada
and South Carolina that will actually
set the tone of course the polling gives
us a sense of how those are going to go
but focus in if you want to see Bernie
carry this through to the nomination
focus in on getting involved in those
four states particularly Iowa and New
Hampshire since those are the first two
I don't think anything is a foregone
conclusion I get emails from people who
delusionally say bernie is definitely
going to be the nominee well that's not
clear but I also get emails from people
who say bernie is done and that's
definitely not the case at this point
Pete Budaj edges rise is evidence of
that he looked like he was out a few
months ago he's now right in there
the polling as high as Burnie and Warren
in some polls in some polls although
he's still in fourth place on average so
my advice to you is if you don't like
what's going on get active
we know the strategy there's four states
four key states that you can get
involved in and it is still early enough
for Bernie Sanders to do very well but
he might not as well and and I think
that only being tied to reality is the
best path forward he's not obviously
going to win he's not obviously going to
lose it's gonna come down to what
happens in the next few months another
post I saw what's happening to David
asks Rickard 58 I'm a longtime listener
of the show David's recent takes on
Latin America and his concern trolling
on Medicare for all have me wondering if
he's moving more to the center or if
he's trying to appeal more to the
intellectual darkweb cultist crowd in
some of his videos what are your
thoughts well two things on this number
one from a qualitative standpoint my
views on these issues none of my views
on these issues have changed I've always
been for Medicare for all but understood
the practical difficulty of making it a
reality and I'm still for Medicare for
all there's been no change my views on
Latin American politics have been the
same for I don't know years and years
and years it may be that my audience is
changing around me it may be that my
audience isn't changing and I'm not
changing but that there are more other
ideas that are getting traction in media
and thus creating a contrast with me
that's certainly a possibility as far as
moving to the center we recently I've
done I've had the pleasure of publicly
doing those political spectrum quizzes
there's so many different ones there's
the eight values one there's political
compass there's one called police kales
or something like that I've done all of
these over the years and I've actually
moved to the left on every single one of
those tests I'm more to the left today
than I ever was so that's I guess all I
have to say about it
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it that's our II D di t